today I thought I'd talk about methane
and the shape of carbon because it's
something that we all take for granted
but once upon a time nobody had any idea
what the shapes the carbon would adopt
would be so it's been known for a long
time now that four coordinate carbon so
that's carbon with four bonds would form
what we call a tetrahedral shape so this
is a tetrahedral shape here actually a
hundred years before I was born
a guy called vant Hoff proposed this and
this was revolutionary at the time and
this became a real cornerstone of
chemistry if you say four coordinate
carbons people immediately think it's a
tetrahedral shape like this and it
wasn't until actually around about the
time I was born nearly a hundred years
later that a Nobel prize-winning chemist
called Hofmann said but what if it was
flat and square and nobody had really
taken this seriously until then and he
did lots of calculations and he found
the reason for this that you don't have
this form is because this form is much
more unstable compared to this form here
but chemists don't like it when they're
told the molecule isn't viable because
it's too unstable so this made people
start to think about well how could we
crack a molecule like this and a few
years later a guy called von Schleicher
said well what happens if we take this
molecule and we take two of those
hydrogens off and replace them with
lithium's does that make it any more
stable and the answer is well possibly
yes but maybe not in this form where the
lithium's are opposite each other and
what he worked out is that if you take a
slightly different form where they're
next to each other it actually becomes
much more feasible as a target to try
and attempt to crack so this is quite
tricky to do so what people decided to
do is to change these hydrogens into
other groups and then this would help us
to isolate individual methane
Yul's and one way to do that is to use
phosphorus and that's because phosphorus
can have other groups appended to it and
then you can try and trap an individual
molecule so then we go for a bit of a
leap from this - which is what we've
actually managed to do recently which is
this as you can see there's quite a
difference here so what this molecule is
is that's a lithium there
here's your phosphorous Center and
there's the other one
and these have got big nice bulky
benzene rings on them so this helps to
keep the whole molecule as an individual
rather than grouping together with its
mates and each phosphorus has a nitrogen
on it which grabs this lithium and pins
it in place so what you can see is
you've got a central carbon here so
that's your methane carbon right there
and there's a lithium there a lithium
there and a phosphorus and phosphorus
and the point is it's nearly planar if
you look at it from the side you can see
the lithium's a little bit above from
where the two phosphorus centres are but
it's really really close and there's a
few examples in the literature now where
people have made these compounds where
carbon has four bonds but it's planar or
really close and this is really exciting
because it helps to validate the
calculations which predicted these
molecules and it's really satisfying as
well because like I said we hate being
told that we can't make molecules so
what we really you know we've pretty
much got to nowadays is we started with
a carbon like this and now we can pretty
much make it do this we've just had this
published in a journal called anger
rancher which is a good journal to be
published in and so hopefully now
everybody in the chemical world will get
to see what we've done now we're going
to go into the lab because seeing this
model is all very well and fine but I
think you should actually get to see
what this compound looks like okay so
this is oli is just coming to the end of
his first year of his PhD and his guy
who made this compound and you can I
show it to ya he is so this compound
like most of the things we make it
wouldn't exist out on a bench in
err so we have to handle it under
nitrogen it's perfectly stable into
nitrogen which is you have to have it
under nitrogen so we've got this sir
glovebox which is full of dry nitrogen
so it can be handled in there as if it
were out on the bench so all he's just
going to produce hands into the gloves
and then he's going to just picks them
out and way out into a boat so you can
actually see it why is it so important
to make this planer molecule he's doing
it for the sake of it yeah it's nothing
wrong with that it's expanding knowledge
improving our knowledge this doesn't
have to have an actual use the point is
if you have predictions it's nice to be
able to validate them because that helps
to validate the actual theory it was
used to make the prediction but it just
pushes out the boundaries of what we
know to be possible and makes us be a
bit more daring about what we try next
you